peut on est dans le ventre de la mère et
c'est tout petit crème et qui rossi qui
grossit qui forment les athés talent des
jambes des bras des mots va trop vite
est vrai et des cheveux qui pousse la
balle bébé né comme ça
oui mais c'est le mars avec de marie
saint cloud avec le mari n'ont pas peur
jésus pas du tout banni à vie longue
liste pour le mari ou gsm est très
différent
allez bon bah c'est ce mari et son fils
sont d'accord mais comment il a fait
c'est pas c'est une graine qui me dit un
gros si comme je t'ai dit il à l'heure
après on est obligé d'aller à les
cliniques ont un très gros ventre là un
très gros ventre et alors elle amasse de
challancin des petits cris c'est pas la
sainte vierge humain à la clinique peau
explique sabah non la sainte vierge ne
ne fait pas l'enfant on prend un but on
dirait l'ami jean même on et des bas
mais bien ça veut dire que vous laisse
deux enfants à temps on met des petits
enfants un monde
bon moi je connais des clauses qu'une
grande fille m'a piqué g jour elle ne
peut pas dire parce que son lit qui
était et est encore trop petit pour
savoir mais je me l'ont dit joël ne pas
le dire alors je peux pas je veux pas
faire mon saut seront peut-être elle
voulait dire que c'est une toute petite
petite petite graine grain
ils grossissent tu sais comme le gerb ce
tout petit mais bientôt
oui elle rien de ben 10 elle vient comme
ça elle venue du camp non c'est pas ça
mais chasse panique mais ce soit une
petite fille que je m'explique bars
amérique nous y voici je te demande ça
m'a dit ce que j'ai sur rudy le ca fait
rien c'est pas elle apprend là on a du
kleenex là pour quand on a un échec
parce qu'il ya non je peux pas le dire
rennes qui comprend du contrat ah oui
est ce qu'un rapport entre les flots
laisse d'or tu crois ce que c'est pareil
non je ne sais pas du tout pareil parce
que un homme et une femme s'habille et
une fleur s'habiller chez les chiens les
chats et chevaux et d'autres animaux la
semence contenant des spermatozoïdes se
forme d'un des mourres ce qu'on appelle
terre testicules voilà aussi l'amour ce
petit testicules voilà nice il y en a
deux venus est destitué ça s'appelle
testicules gas salut je m'en sors par le
sexe non je comprends pas ils disent
cette semaine sort par le sexe on sait
par willem sexe c'est parce que ces
sexes
je trouve qu'ils ont mis des choses tout
compliqué des mots compliqués que les
enfants ne comprennent pas l semences du
père doit parvenir à l'aube il que la
mère pendant son corps bien
donc contrairement à qui se passe chez
les animaux l'homme et la femme sont
poussés à s'unir ainsi par un puissant
élan d'amour et de tendresse et donc
pourquoi l'amour à latendresse a fait le
bébé parce que bon tu quoque chat huant
cas de départ en bonbons mêmes garçons
viennent quelqu'un énormément de temps
en temps envie de te rapprocher lui
qu'est ce qui se passe quand tu aimes
kaka énormément
[Musique]